mexique cuba états unis plus de 200 vols
internationaux arrivée au canada depuis
le début de l'année transporté au moins
un passager a peint de la coved 19 sél
agence de la santé publique du canada
qui met cette liste à jour afin d'aviser
les voyageurs qui ont été assis dans les
rangées exposés aux coronavirus alors
qu'au début et puis les nih ont laissé
un siège aux deux maintenant les avions
la semaine dernière deux vols d'air
transat ont atterri à montréal en
provenance d'haïti dans lesquelles tous
les passagers ont été exposés à la queue
vide
on ignore pour le moment combien de cas
étaient positifs et combien de passagers
étaient à bord et les appareils ont une
capacité de 300 personnes la santé
publique savait qu'ils avaient cette
possibilité là pour jean ernest pierre
la situation n'est pas surprenante
depuis le 7 janvier ottawa exige un test
négatif pour les passagers revenant de
l'étranger sauf pour ceux en provenance
d'haïti
je crois qu haïti doit être un pays doit
être traité comme tous les autres pays
si les gens qui veulent voyager qu'ils
s'agissent d'haïtiens ou de canadiens
d'origine haïtienne ou de canadiens
québécois
il faut qu'il suive les règles il est
souvent insuffisant malheureusement et
il faut pas non plus détourner la
population va des voyageurs
internationaux
il faut donc plus de mesures pour
contrôler les voyageurs c'est ce que
réclament les partis d'opposition il ya
certainement plus à faire la part du
gouvernement fédéral on parle de quoi
pour bien contrôler donc être seul match
qu'on fait c'est de se fier au bon
vouloir des gens les agents du à lyon
aucun pouvoir
qwest il faut clairement fédéral
travaille avec les provinces et les
municipalités pour faire en sorte que le
suivi de cette quarantaine ne soit le
plus strictes possibles en ce moment
c'est n'importe quoi
un resserrement que les médecins aussi
réclament on a déjà perdu je pense la
bataille pour la variante 2 2 du royaume
uni on va essayer de pas perdre
la bataille pour d'autres pas rien
issigeac audrey charbonneau radio canada
montréal